when Germany opened its doors to welcome
Syrian refugees fleeing war 1.1 million
people flooded in over two years most
were Syrian followed by Afghans and
Iraqis when happiness ala al Vanya Vanya
today the Syrians we met in 2015 are
being integrated while the country is
trying to deport Afghans and Iraqis
who've been denied Asylum pardon me sir
a new name again na - almond how many
exon and what's again guru this
September Germans will vote in federal
elections that will signal how the
country feels about Chancellor Angela
Merkel last year gains made by the
far-right AFD party in parliamentary
elections were viewed as a damning
referendum on Merkel's open-door refugee
policy Germany is a Christian country
and yes Islam is not a part of Germany
we returned to Germany to see what the
promised land holds for the refugees who
made it in before the border shut
[Music]
in 2015 Hamidah crossed into Germany
with her husband Assad Allah and son
Hadi their baby melissa was born three
months ago in a refugee camp in Berlin
the Afghan family now lives in a
container home on the outskirts of town
in Joel betcha within your boredom hey
goober hey Melissa dakedo run behind
which is about you carry poober Bassam
that's my own accord or Ashok have you
been granted asylum much opened there
the sign couldn't get over the ocean
from the demo are you guys worried about
being deported trailer from Suncoast
issue behind water from ala moana
Testament barium and aluminum yourself
on women army Germany doesn't consider
Afghanistan a war zone and ascending the
Afghans who were denied Asylum back to
Kabul while we were editing this story
Kabul experienced one of its worst
bombings ever the latest in growing
violence in the country
Ronald Glasser of the AFD party wants
even Syrians to go home when their war
ends the AFD one state parliamentary
seats last year by exploiting the
anti-refugee sentiment that followed
several attacks carried out by
immigrants like the New Year's Eve
assault in Cologne we don't want to to
wake up in a third world country or the
province of Africa so if we accept
immigration to our country the better
the higher skill they are the better it
would be but we cannot be flooded with
so many illegal immigrants that our
grandchildren will no longer live in
Germany have you seen any evidence of a
developed country losing its identity
and becoming a third world country
because it accepted immigrants
well which is this is a bad comparison
but look at what happened in parts of
South Africa what it's very insecure
today since the black population has
gotten all the the power but this is a
bad comparison yeah because it's Africa
yeah how do you respond to your critics
who say you are a racist party and an
islamaphobe ik party
this is this is part of the political
process to to insult you in your
competitor and saying you're racist well
that's not true
I told you're not racist no no of course
I'm not you're not something phobic no
I'm not I asked Ronald to join me in a
restaurant opened by a Syrian refugee
who came to Germany in 2015 must eat
something we just had breakfast too so
maybe we'll just have tea one of the AF
DS biggest gripes is the billions
Germany is spending to help refugees
most of whom remain on welfare and will
need years to fully integrate I have no
problems with was really grants from all
over the world but they're saying is we
have several economic and cultural
problems with people from Turkey and
Arabian countries they have higher crime
rates they are more likely to be
unemployed so there are a lot of reasons
why this harder to integrate them but
most of the groups who came to our
country in highest numbers
the AFD says it represents the silent
majority a term also used in the US by
President Trump but these Syrian
refugees dismissed the aft as fringe
marking homicides this Mariana normally
have no animosity say a lot of the
animosity out of the water and have a
problem we heard that often from Syrian
refugees here but the Afghans who remain
in refugee camps feel differently so
we're walking into
Tempelhof which is a massive former
airport that was built by the Nazis now
it houses refugees and at the height of
the crisis there were more refugees
living here than any other place in
Berlin those living in cramped quarters
here are Afghans who've been denied
Asylum
Kasana k2 in camp and docile well
embarrassed and labelled as the Margay
the Manship Haddam have a de minimis la
mouche Middleford as film by chan meters
away when a developer with the bottom
equation in German Russia began a
memorable my champion became a Sonny
Chisholm a phenomena tuna yawning
cavalryman the road machine guru demon
guru Ram Solomon in general for Tunisia
it's also true at an hammer Darren
vimanam aconitine camper have you gotten
asylum no that was upon an agreement I'm
not sure the name again of each other
well II Tara's gonna sound like Iliad of
time when I'm watching but a
high-ranking official in the interior
ministry told us they're determined to
deport Afghans who have been denied
Asylum
they will have no prospects no prospects
of getting asylum here very little
prospects of getting asylum here and if
they are not entitled to asylum they
will be returned and they need to know
that
do you have numbers on how many Afghans
have been returned to Afghanistan
the numbers are not very not very high
what we notice every time a return
flight is being planned Afghans get wind
of it and they simply vanished
it's a problem we are going to we're
going to deal with it and Afghans need
to know their prospect prospect for
getting protection in Germany is lower
than 50 percent in May the German
channel koala news 5
captured a video that went viral showing
hundreds of students in Nuremberg
clashing with police to try to stop them
from taking an Afghan student for
deportation in a recent study German
said they're largely in support of
welcoming refugees but also think the
country has reached its limit many we
talked to said the same that's a squeaks
fleshling isn't that four million but
kanava safe as a lion as awesome creaks
a bit Phoenician rested our cottage a
furnace because every liquid fire in a
man's own daughter as a letter also a
version of auntie Medusa to harm myth
Renea Tong born aunty aussie gave mom
the Hydra gas negative
[Music]
the idea that freeloaders took advantage
of Germany's open doors is even more
prevalent in rural regions like where
Muhammad a Syrian we met in 2015 now
lives even while waiting on the border
Muhammad told us he didn't want to be a
burden we're trying to be polite we're
trying to be a good refugees with a good
future
we first met him on a bus in Austria
that was shuttling people to the German
border where are you guys from all of
you and your family yeah he's my cousin
he's my brother he's my other cousin
and therein sees my friends the guys
have since split up moving wherever they
could find opportunity Mohammed got an
internship in the countryside and is
renting a room in a family's home our
cameras attracted a curious neighbor
Paul Schaffer t-bob more time I have
been one more time you know I was
electron Genuity Google does not Alice
Clark alles klar doctor physician does
he's in there enough for pretty much
kind of emotional for me to see him
busting out fluent German talking his
German neighbors when the last time I
saw him he had just taken like a
life-threatening journey and you know
crossed into Germany super tired
uncertain future so very proud of you I
was saying I'm very emotional seeing you
talk German and you know course I took
German I mean you know the last time I
saw you you guys were just like super
exhausted and you barely made it and
you're almost drowned and you almost had
your stuff stolen and oh no I don't know
what to tell you but you know living
here it's like it's like you'll get this
chance only either you will prove
yourself or you'll go with there with
other people I don't want to take money
from government anymore
Hamid's off welfare and feels his
internship may lead to a job goals he
set out to achieve when we first met a
bunch of people right now are about to
board a free bus to the border you told
us to get on that bus remember yeah
because you where you were choking in
English and you were talking and then I
thought hey this is someone talking
English maybe I can explain something
with it I have to send a message that we
are not just extra beauties we're
engineers we are doctors we are lawyers
we are scientists so
in our country and see most of us they
don't have a good or a pacer education
yeah so for me I would like to continuum
us that all to work there as I thought
you are you are working all I'm thinking
about now is just to be in Germany once
you're in Germany everything will be
okay
has it been okay yeah I can say like
it's for 70 percent it's not not
everything was okay
I mean it's not really easy the
government here asks the people to
integrate of course we need to integrate
we need to learn the language we need to
respect the rules we need to expect the
people we need to respect the traditions
here I am really a hundred percent with
that but you cannot just tell someone
who was in a war and now we become here
he what he need to start from zero I
mean it's not a way to deal with people
that really have they come from war the
path to creating a new life in Germany
is a long and often difficult one to get
far you need to speak German and most
asylum seekers still don't and it can be
lonely Hamid hopes to marry his fiancee
who's in Syria and have her join him
when you think about the fact that we're
in this like really nice coffee shop in
a beautiful European city and you
contrast that to what's happening in
Syria right now what does it make you
feel when I'm talking to my cousin like
we're talking every two weeks for
example I'm telling him hey what's going
on he's telling me thanks God we're
still alive it's like that I mean well
I'd like around her it's like it's like
he don't know when it's going to be a
bumping but it will be someday we don't
know when we don't know where maybe he
will be there or maybe he will not this
is the problem I mean I'm feeling shy to
tell him that I'm good I'm feeling shy
to tell him that I'm going everywhere I
mean I'm feeling shame that's sometimes
I forget myself and I used to live here
people are guilty being me of course but
at the end this is my life I mean I got
scared like everyone else everyone gets
scared for his life
everyone wants his life to be good so
everyone is asking me are you going to
back to Syria I don't know what the
future will be how the future will be
maybe I'll go back maybe not I don't
know I don't have any clue about that
when Germans return to the polls this
fall the world will be watching to see
whether the country joins a tide of
populist right-wing fervor seen across
Europe meanwhile Syrians like Muhammad
will continue trying to fit into German
society while many Afghans who also
entered the country when he did may have
to bid it farewell so that's what's
going on now if you want to check out
our first journey across Europe in 2015
including when we met refugees like
Mohammad check out these next videos